welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host definition and this
is the channel where we explain it so
you don't have to any film that deals in
time travel
often comes with a wealth of plot holes
and avengers end game is no different
those who've seen the film will know
that there are several large and looming
paradoxes created in the film's final
snapping that carry a lot of confusion
with them
so to clear things up i thought i'd put
together a breakdown of how the
timelines in the film work and how its
contradictory elements come together to
form a cohesive narrative
this is full spoilers ahead so if you
haven't seen the film yet
and don't want to know what happens then
i highly suggest that you turn off now
with that out the way thank you for
clicking on this video i hope you enjoy
it now sit back relax
and let's explain how the paradoxes work
in avengers endgame
okay so the big bit of confusion that
surrounds avengers endgame
revolves around the fact that the
avengers managed to defeat the 2014
version of thanos before he ever has the
chance to carry out the snap that caused
the events in the film
this is more commonly known in
theoretical physics as the grandfather
paradox
the grandfather paradox involves a
person traveling through time to kill
their own grandfather before the
conception of their father or mother
this becomes a paradox because in doing
this the time traveler will never be
born and therefore cannot travel back in
time to kill their grandfather
yes it's a lot of timey-wimey stuff
anyway we see
a similar scenario happen in avengers
end game when nebula kills a past self
surely the rules of time travel
stipulate that in doing this
the future version of nebula should not
exist and therefore she would not be
able to kill the past version of herself
and yeah my head's starting to hurt now
those who've seen the movie looper will
know that this was used to great effect
in the film's finale
as a way for the protagonist to take out
the villainous version of himself from
the future
however in endgame nebula doesn't
disappear and when tony stark later
kills thanos in the film
the timeline isn't destroyed even though
it should be because thanos was never
around to carry out the snap in infinity
war that led to the avengers being
forced to travel through time
so why exactly is this well there are
two possibilities that seem the most
likely
the first one i've seen that whilst i
don't really agree with still could
potentially be the case and this
revolves around the way that tony
carried out the snap
when doing this in one of the film's
best moments and completely dusting all
of thanos forces i've seen some
theorized that tony did not actually
completely kill them
and instead returned them to their
original timeline
where they were completely unaware of
the incident and therefore continued
life on the predetermined path that they
did
the other theory and one that seems most
likely comes from bruce banner's
conversation with the ancient one
she states that when something has
changed in the past such as the infinity
stones being removed
a new timeline is created and one that
angles are from the original reality
this is backed up in other mcu movies
namely doctor strange
in that film when discussing the
warnings on the time stone we also get
confirmation from this from mordor who
states
that part the following manipulations
can create branches in time
unstable dimensional openings spatial
paradoxes time loops
therefore it's safe to assume that what
the avengers actually did was create
multiple branching realities and
dimensions which alternative characters
can exist in
so when nebula kills herself she's
actually killing herself from an
alternative reality
similar to something like the one
starring jet li which
by the way definitely deserves a remake
anyway
this also carries over for thanos and
his black order
their alternative dimension versions are
killed and therefore a timeline is
created where the avengers never have to
face him down
infinity war doesn't happen and tony
probably gets to grow old with his
daughter morgan who loves cheeseburgers
just as much as i do
though tony is sacrificing his own
happiness in the end he's also creating
a version of himself that will get to
experience it
similar to how captain america seeks to
have some happiness in the finale of the
film
remember doctor strange said that there
are 14 million branching paths to take
in defeating thanos
so it's a safe assumption to make that
there are different timelines operating
all at once
marvel are clearly putting alternative
dimensions in place as they are already
producing a peggy carter show for disney
plus which centers around what would
have happened if she'd taken the super
soldier serum instead of steve rogers
the final question that's created if
this is the case is how does steve
rogers return to reality prime at the
end
well though we don't get confirmation of
this it is possible that this version of
steve rogers was always part of peggy
carter's life and we just didn't know
about it
there have been references to her
husband though we've never got
confirmation of this
she also keeps a picture of steve on a
desk which seems like a strange thing to
do
if the two never hooked up is this photo
instead a memory that she wants to keep
around to remind her at work of who's
went back home
i'd like to think so and perhaps steve
kept out of the limelight because he
knew that if he were to step forward it
would create problems
and it would also be awkward at family
dinners because yet
he kissed his niece i just hope it's not
a blood relative
in the end though he couldn't miss that
final passing of the torch to sam
just in the same way that he couldn't
miss that final dance and that's why he
decides to re-emerge once more to let
his friends know that in the end he
found happiness
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the timeline and if you have a
different theory comment below and let
me know
if you loved this video 3 000 then make
sure you give it a thumbs up
and check out my full breakdown of
steve's mission and how we return the
soul stone which will be linked at the
end
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes
so if that's the kind of thing you like
hit subscribe thanks again for taking
the time to watch this
i've been definition you've been the
best and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you